yo what has been um this year there the  Grammy nomination just came out what's  what's your favorite album of the year  that's not your own music that's  non-p p r e [ __ ] that you could be like  I like the the angle I don't even know  who nominated bro no I'm saying just in  general this year what's like one of  your favorite items that's that's  dropped this year  it's quiet  then comes to mind  like real talk um you don't listen to a  lot I'd be out of sight bro yeah what do  you listen to  like if you're in the car and you're not  listening to your own [ __ ] you're  listening to podcasts you're listening  to [ __ ] James Brown like what are you  doing right  cheeky Dobby  future  that's the most Memphis way when someone  say future  yeah low part drip  uh globery  Jay fizzle Snoop bands  shout out to baby money too baby money  is fire as well in Canada money